a new report in Indiana has found that
thousands of dead people are still
registered to vote yes yeah
which explains why today Donald Trump
held four rallies and three seances
juicy watch anybody
[Applause]
[Music]
and pull the lever and then a lot of
problems for the Trump campaign analysts
are speculating that communication
between Donald Trump and his campaign
manager Kellyanne Conway has become
practically non-existent yeah
they say if she spoke to Trump any less
they'd be married all the men are like
it's come out that Donald Trump has
spent a large portion of his campaign
donations buying copies of his own book
art of the deal yeah
Trump supporters are angry that he
misused their money and even angrier
that he bought a book
of course y'all saw this over the
weekend a porn actress called a press
conference where she accused Donald
Trump of offering her ten thousand
dollars for sex yeah she said given his
history with contractors I was worried
he would stiff me and then stiff me
[Applause]
Vatican in the news that always gets my
attention the Vatican has issued new
guidelines on cremation saying Catholics
must bury the ashes in a cemetery yeah
just too bad because I wanted my ashes
to be a secret ingredient on the show
chopped
that's kind of Conan II yeah yeah well
it's got a Conan crumble that's got a
[ __ ] fall
scientists have discovered your nuts is
true scientists have discovered a new
kind of insect that has four penises
yeah yeah the insect is described as
exhausted and he lives alone what you
don't want to you want to show
favoritism got to keep it equal a a
youth football team in Rhode Island I
just spit incredibly on that Joe can you
go back and try and find I don't know
what happened I just said youth football
team and literally I think a quart of
spit came out of my mouth and does it
come out
I'm sorry I was a horrible I've been
doing this a long time right I'm the
host of the show and I Spit on these
people yeah
a youth football team in Rhode Island
was kicked out of its league after they
snuck an adult man into their starting
lineup that really happened they snuck
an adult man in there on the bright side
Tim Tebow scored 12 touchdown
[Applause]
you